uh well i first met our next speaker and
his lovely wife penny way back in the
last decade
of the last century that sounds like a
long time ago
it was at the time i was studying for my
phd
in political science at the claremont
graduate school and he was the president
of the claremont institute
and uh what i quickly learned about him
is something that hillsdale students
learn about him today and that is that
he's a teacher
at heart he's a teacher and he's always
teaching
he didn't teach any formal classes back
then but he
you know we we graduate students learned
a lot from him he was always busy but he
always took the time
to talk to us as he does with hillsdale
students
today another thing we learned about him
is that if you claim to know something
turns you into something of a right
target
i was targeted quite frequently
well if you come and see us in hillsdale
and visit us on campus and we hope you
will
you'll see that he hasn't changed a bit
he's still teaching
and today he's offering classes on a
variety of subjects
like aristotle the constitution and c.s
lewis
and he's still pushing his students to
defend their opinions and think them
through
more deeply because the goal of
education after all is discovering
the truth and that's not easy it's been
my privilege and honor to work with him
at hillsdale now for 20 years
his topic today is politics and
education would you please welcome back
to the podium
the 12th president of hillsdale college
larry p.r
thanks larry
tim makes me feel old that was all 400
years ago when i met him
thank you tim tim's a good student
um okay i'll give you an invitation to
start since he mentioned it
if you come to the college any week when
i'm in town
and they're known a year in advance so
you find out
i'll take you to lunch and i go eat
lunch in the dining hall with the
students
and i'm the only old guy who always sits
with the with the students
and uh it's a hoot it's the greatest
thing in the world and
you can always get them to say that
something is good
and then ask them what it means for a
thing to be good and then
chaos breaks out so it's uh
please come i'm delighted to see you all
it's a crowd wow is that legal
the right to assemble and the right to
associate are much underrated these days
aren't they
so i'm going to talk about uh education
in the crisis of the time
and mary graybar gives me a good jumping
off point it's her wonderful talk thank
you mary
turns out that there was a panel she
mentioned it she was on it
she's the one who talked about howard
zinn and it was formed by the white
house on constitution
day september 17th and
we had a conference going in washington
and we always have one
on the week of september 17th
and i had to miss the day of it because
i was invited to be on that panel too i
was the moderator of the panel
and it was an extraordinary thing
it was an initiative in the white house
i know the people who thought it up and
there's a lot of them there that think
like that many of them are hillsdale
graduates
and what we were to do on this panel
was uh lay first a diagnosis and then a
prescription for recovering the truth
about american history
remarkable initiative and we were
sitting in front of the in the national
archives in front of the declaration of
independence the constitution the
original of those things
very beautiful place and then when we
were done the big show came in
in the persons of mike pence and donald
trump
and then trump gave a speech and it was
about
the beauty of the american founding in
american history and the importance of
teaching it
and the importance to the freedom of our
country and the continuation of
civilization
and i was sitting i had to be sitting
well we all were there weren't many
people there i was sitting about 15 feet
from him
and it was masterful i thought
and uh while it was going on here's what
i was thinking
uh 400 years ago even before i met tim
caspar
i i went to graduate school
and what did i learn from a great
teacher we
brian kennedy is here doug jeffrey is
here
we were graduate students and some of us
because i'm among the oldest of them now
i was the youngest back then um
we started a think tank and its purpose
was the claremont institute its purpose
was two things
and we both learned them from our
teacher and one was to
explain that the great turning points in
american history
have always turned on the principles in
the declaration of independence and the
forms of government that are stated in
the constitution
they constitute the formal and the final
cause of the united states of america
which are the two most important causes
of anything
and that you can see this sublimely in
the statesmanship of the founders of the
country
and also of abraham lincoln in the
second great crisis in american history
and we thought that this
following this was uh
simply crucial to recovering the freedom
of our land
and i will say that we've all been
working on this like i went to hillsdale
college in
20 years ago now i've now worked there
longer than i worked at the claremont
institute i am really old
and why did i go well first of all i
i thought being a college president was
a fool's errand
and you know everybody in this room if
you want to be a college president you
may be
because there's a thousand jobs a year
that come open and
there's nobody to take them because not
everybody's stupid
but this one which i refused for months
i discovered then by accident mostly
that hillsdale college was founded by
people who worked in the cause of
abraham lincoln and some of them were
friends of his
and i went goodness gracious
of course i love that kind of thing and
i thought that that would be the
principle according to which to run the
college
because principle that word means first
but it also means essential and you can
see that that has to be
because the first thing
in a thing has to be defining of that
thing
because anything that comes later this
is not the same thing well that wouldn't
be
that first thing wouldn't be first
anymore right so it's the first things
are always terribly important
that's what that word means in primus
is that name is a variation
on the on that latin and it means in the
first place
the second thing we were taught to think
it was uh
an essay by a great teacher harry jaffa
who's
formative of many of us he was he taught
aristotle and abraham lincoln better
than anything else also shakespeare
now that i think of it
he wrote an essay called on the
necessity of a scholarship of the
politics of freedom
it's kind of a long title right but you
have to have a
scholarship to support
the principles that a nation like ours
our nation
is the most deliberate nation in history
our nation was built by people for
a reason that stated in the legal
document that founds the country
and the and the principle and the
reasons are given in
abstract and universal terms
and so those principles can be turned
into
anything except there be good
scholarship
and i thought that day on constitution
day
two weeks ago i thought that was the
greatest exhibition of those two things
put together that i have ever seen
and i think they offer promise for the
future
even though it's a dark time and
terrible things
penned if things don't get better
so today i'm going to talk about the
scholarship
of the politics of freedom in particular
about history
about the way it's taught about what it
means
that we change it
uh a bunch of us who were on that panel
uh
roger kimball stanley stanley kurtz
wasn't on anybody helped form it
bill mcclay bill mcclay who wrote land
of hope is coming to work at hillstock
college
next year and then thereafter as i say
to him forever
and he's a wonderful guy right and
and it's come i can't remember who who
dug this up but uh
president trump has been attached
attacking the 1619 project
and it's amazing how although they won't
cover what he does it still has
consequences because
they're a little embarrassed now because
this thing
claims to be claimed in its beginning to
be
an account of the american revolution
and that's a thing in the past i'm going
to say something about that in a minute
and it isn't and so then now it's been
now it's been discovered
that uh in the digital archive of the
new york times
they've changed some of the documents by
which they announced that project
to remove the claim that it is a true
account
of american history and
one of the first words in the pure
pulitzer prize-winning new york times
column by nicole hannah jones is her
name
says that the founders of america
knew that the principles they adopted
were false when they adopted them
it's actually a truer thing to say that
they knew that that
article she was writing was false when
she wrote it
and they have tacitly admitted that by
altering the thing and you know
if you make a mistake in the academic
world
then you go back and fix it because you
know we're all human we all make
mistakes
but you also say that you're fixing it
and they have not that they have not
done that saying
and that's an interesting thing it means
that
in their view you heard mary talk about
it too
howard zinn's book which is obviously
false now proven by mary's book to be
false
is not really consistently defended as
an account of the truth
it's a perspective she showed
a reaction to one to her book that she
doesn't want
women you know first of all women
people of colors you know when you all
those up you get most everybody all
except the men
and white men i guess and and uh
you know i realize that we're a bad
cadre
but you know there's some crime in every
human soul
right and
you don't look for the truth now i want
to just explain to you how serious that
is
it's not just that our country is at
stake
it is humanity itself
is at stake civilization
the cultivation of human life to a state
of goodness
is at stake and will be wiped out by
this it's much more
radical than just destroying america
and i'll tell you how i know that
i'm teaching a course i've done it twice
before i started about six years ago
on totalitarian novels you know what
they are
1984 darkness at noon
that hideous strength brave new world
there's some others
those are the best i think and it's
really
i've decided now because things are so
tough in the country so dangerous in the
country that it's kind of a gloomy
experience to teach this
and it's a new genre
the totalitarian novel the word
totalitarian is a 20th century word
the older word is tyranny the rule of
one person
or small group of people in their own
interest and according to their will
that's what aristotle's definition of
tyranny is the worst form of government
possible
totalitarianism that means something
that reaches farther and more
and in the end an attempt to reach
everything
and totalitarianism is made possible by
modern science
by the technology see the old word
science means to know
the latin word the new word technology
comes from a greek word that means to
make
techne art make and so now we're not so
much seeking to know when we study
nature
now we're seeking to make things to
remake nature
and that spirit and move has great
very greatly empowered human beings
in 1984 there's a
telescreen everywhere and also
microphones
all over the place that you can't see
and everything you do
is watched actually not quite everything
but you can't be sure when you're being
watched
and they uh it emerges toward the end of
the novel that they become
experts at judging looks on people's
faces
and the organization that monitors all
this is called the thought police
because it's like what herodotus says
about the persians
in the beginning of his history of the
of the persian war he says in persia
it was considered illegal to think
anything it was illegal to do
you see so controlling people's thoughts
and the word totalitarian means control
everything
i mean if that sounds far-fetched in
china right now uh
there are cameras everywhere and and uh
everything
people do on social media is watched
algorithms run now you don't need people
to do it as much as before
although they got plenty of people whose
job is to watch and you get a social
score
and if you don't do the right things all
the time then you won't be able to buy a
plane ticket or stuff
things happen to you might lose your job
it's very comprehensive it's not
in general cruel the way the one in 1984
is but i'll get to that
and in the middle of this novel 1984
history occupies the central place
the protagonist is a man named winston
smith he's actually named by george
orwell after winston churchill and you
know
uh george orwell and arthur kirsler
wrote darkness at noon and aldous huxley
wrote brave new world and c.s lewis
wrote that hideous strength
and those people are all rough
contemporaries
and they knew each other and they
reviewed each other's books
and they all knew winston churchill too
and he knew them had correspondence with
all of them
and so these people are thinking about
something that's emerged in the world
that's brand new
winston smith the protagonist
has a job and his job is actually to
rewrite history
he sits at a little table and he's got
to tell the inevitable telescreen in
front of him watching everything he does
and he's got a microphone over here and
over here is a
they call it the memory hole and
they put things in them and they waft
off somewhere and
are probably burned although he can't be
certain
and what does he do a little tube falls
out of a
little cylinder falls out of a pneumatic
tube
and in there there's a piece of work for
him
and the typical one now the piece of
work might and uh uh
might concern something huge like
with whom are we at war
it might concern something small what
about this
middle level bureaucrat or this soldier
was he a hero
or a villain and so
he his job is to
read what's said about the change
there's a change see
uh the nation is always at war
and the fiction is is it fiction
that it's always been at war with
whomever it is at war now
and although people have living memory
of a change in with whom they're at war
still to say that is
not just death also torture and winston
smith's job
is to rewrite every reference
in every book periodical or newspaper
every written thing that makes reference
to what used to be thought the truth and
then
everything is reprinted
and that can concern a war which means
it's all over the place
or that concern uh he he once invented a
new
person to become a hero because somebody
who'd been condemned as a traitor
had been resurrected by the party just
by a change of opinion
and that means that that publications
are now
fluid they flow like a river
and they're altering the past
and if you just think about it for a
minute think of the labor
that would be involved in that think of
how many people would have to do it
and there's a good film of this starring
john hurt
and in the film they show the room where
he does it and there are people
in such cubicles as far as the eye can
see but there would have to be millions
to do this right
and the question is why is it worth the
effort
why do they do that and winston smith
who's
disaffected with the regime and yet must
constantly control everything he says
every look on his face
they learn to do that they're waked in
the morning to do calisthenics
health care is not very good they're
sore
life is dingy and food is
poor and by the way from the telescreen
constantly pours out statements of how
much better everything's getting
all the time the
chocolate ration is up 25
uh that's the announcement they made
when it was cut 35
and everybody has to accept that right
well winston does a terrible thing he
opens a diary
and he's aware that
because it's his job he's aware
that things that used to be said to be
true
are now different things are said and
mutually exclusive things
are said and that that is some
attempt to change reality and he doesn't
understand the motive for it he does it
it's his work and it makes him cynical
and disaffected from the regime
but why do it and throughout the novel
this question
recurs why why
do we do this
well the answer comes in one of the most
remarkable scenes in literature
it's the penultimate thing in the book
winston you know winston by the way
meets a girl and all that's strictly
controlled
the family is important because
the regime needs babies
but for another reason that i'll get to
when i explain the final reason for all
this
but the women are raised that they're
not supposed to enjoy sex with their
husbands they're just to do it for the
party
and uh
the children are and this is
characteristic by the way this is the
actual way
that things work in china today and did
work in the soviet union in nazi germany
your children have to go to school and
they are
indoctrinated and they are taught to be
spies
on you in fact the big organization in
1984 for young children is the spies
and they denounce their parents and the
parents live in terror
of their children all the time
think how miserable that is right and in
a way
that's better than the regime in in
brave new world where the children are
manufactured in a factory
and everybody sleeps around everybody
else everyone belongs to everybody else
is the principal
it's better because think of the control
that comes from that
they don't intend to extinguish a
mother's
love they tend to capitalize they intend
to capitalize on that
and subject the mother because she loves
the children which is why she has them
and cares for them when they're little
to there being agents
in the household
it's uh there's a guy named parsons in
it who's supposed to be the most
harmless guy in the world
and it's because of that that he gets
arrested
and put through the mill and his
children have
denounced him and
so why oh winston meets this girl
it's very charming they actually set up
a household
in the in the proletarian regions where
the proletarians so there's the
inner party and they're the powers and
there's the outer party and they're
actually the most miserable people on
earth
they're the ones that the inner party
works on all the time and then there's
the proles and they live out in a
relatively unregulated area and the and
winston ventures out into that areas
from time to time once he goes to a
prostitute
but
he finds a little shop and he buys at
this where he buys his diary
and he and his woman who meets who's
also a member of the outer party
and she's very clever and she's very
good at evading the rules and seeming
entirely enthusiastic for them
and she hooks up with winston and they
have like a
family that's possible under this
distorted situation they have a place
this room above this little shop out in
nowhere
where it's safe and there's no
telescreen
in it and they carry on a love affair
there but also
she buys a dress she finds one on the
black market and she wears the dress
like a normal person not like a uniforms
that are ubiquitous
in this regime and they get real coffee
and so it's kind of like a private world
for two people
of course they couldn't imagine having
children be killed for that
heartbeat well it turns out that there
is a telescreen in this room
and it turns out that this shopkeeper
who seems like a kindly old man is in
fact a member of the thought police
and the shop is kept there to trap
people
so there's no getting away and it
emerges in the
timeline of the novel that uh winston
smith started developing his
deviant thoughts about 12 years ago but
the party has been watching him for
seven
and letting him go until he does a lot
and then they arrest him in that love
nest they have
right and they're and they have made
pledges to one another and the pledges
they make is
they can't make us betray each other
they can make us
say whatever we they want to make us say
and we will say it
but in our hearts we will not betray
each other
and that is the limit on their power
later in the novel winston smith
imagines
that he seems to have been broken and
come completely around there has to be
one more step i'll tell you what that is
and he thinks that his that because he
he really has been tortured for months
and he uh he thinks that what's going to
happen is
they're going to shoot him in the back
of the head one of these days which is
the preferred
method of execution of both the
nazis and the soviet union you walk in
darkness at noon
the protagonist walks down a hallway
in a dungeon after he's confessed to
crimes that he didn't commit
and somewhere along the hallway without
any ceremony with no one else around
somebody shoots him in the back of the
head and so there's not even
a particular place where it's done
it's just eradication see
and winston thinks that's going to
happen to him but he's going to beat
them because
in the second before the bullet goes
into his brain
he's going to release mentally his
hatred for the regime
it emerges that the regime also knows
that's his plan
now in in one of the most uh remarkable
things in literature that i've ever seen
the full meaning of the regime is
revealed and it's an answer to don
thorsen's question that he asked earlier
in a scene of torture winston is taught
while he's being tortured it's a seminar
for a totalitarian regime and he's on a
rack
and uh he's been beaten and kicked and
starved
for months and then he's uh
got back to health a little bit and then
he's taken in and then he goes and
the man's name is o'brien in the film
he's played by richard burton and it's
really good
and he questions winston and he explains
to him
winston thinks that he remembers a
particular photograph
of some people from a newspaper that
shows that those people
could not possibly have been in the
place to commit the crimes that they
publicly confessed to
and in the moscow show trials that
happened all the time
you know these all these you know in in
when the communist revolution happened
in 1917
uh they went into the home of a
ballerina in saint petersburg it's a
museum now you can go there
and there's a photograph on the wall of
all of them lined up
right and linen's in the middle and
trotsky's right here and
and bucharan is right here they're the
most important ones
and then stalin who's a peasant is way
off on the end
and the interesting thing is they
started out like that with lenin
superior and the rest of them sort of
equals
and by 1939 stalin had
executed everybody in that picture who
had not already died of natural causes
and they were his equals right and he'd
become the boss because he was a very
candy man
and they confessed to crimes they could
not have committed
knowing that they were going to be shot
in a dungeon anonymously
after they did it and you know darkness
at noon
is the novel that explains why they did
that and i won't tell you now but you
should read the novel it's
it's maybe the best of these novels but
1984 is the most dramatic for this
reason
uh o'brien leads winston smith to
knowledge
first he says that uh winston has to
learn
doublethink and that's their term for
for
thinking in ways that defy the law of
contradiction
and we learn in aristotle's metaphysics
that the law of contradiction is the
basis of all reasoning
it's the only way we can order the world
and all it means it means a simple thing
it means that x and not x
cannot exist at the same time if they're
mutually exclusive
it means that that you
if a is taller than b and b is taller
than c
c cannot be shorter than a just things
like that
right and it's in parsing things like
that that we
arrive at the truth
now in human affairs
the part of the truth that we can know
is all in the past right because the
president is fleeting and confusing and
we don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow
and the future's not here not here yet i
heard one of our guests
telling john cevini that they'd they'd
started a school somewhere and it's
going to be called the future school
well what are they going to teach
you know they're going to make up some
stuff right
but the past the past
is complete and by the way that that
means that it's the only thing in human
affairs that you can have sure knowledge
of
right because like how do you make a
practical judgment all this is in
aristotle
uh you know you do it you watch all the
circumstances swirling around
all the time and they affect everything
we do in fact our mental weather dwells
upon them mostly when we got to choose
but then there's something outside them
that talks to us a sense of the good
that that commands us in a certain way
while we cope with
and you know in some circumstances you
would do things that in
other circumstances would be wrong
but you have to arrive just like in when
you don't have to do something that
would otherwise be wrong
you have to arrive at an explanation why
it's right
by combining two things an accurate
account of the circumstances around you
and your sense of right well
these circumstances because they're
changing
you only know them while while you're
looking at them
when you look away they might be
different and that means you got to
always be checking i mean you guys
you make hard decisions right one of my
rules for making hard decisions is
don't make it till you have to maybe
it'll go away
and anyway you'll probably know more i
mean god i've done that like a hundred
times about these stupid shutdowns right
you know i'm trying to have college and
the governor didn't want it
so far it's hillsdale college one
governor nothing
uh
[Applause]
so that's current that's the prison
right and that's what it looks like it
looks like emotion
but the past aristotle says and thomas
aquinas repeats and other philosophers
this alone is denied even to god
to make what has been not to have been
you see once it happened it happened
and if it both happened and didn't
happen no understanding is possible
see that's the law of contradiction
right c.s lewis explains
that you know because it's such a cussed
world
and we're so wicked why would a good god
make it
and this explanation of that is that
god can make us free and ma
and god can make us unerringly good
but he can't do both those things
because then we wouldn't be free
free and unfree are not possible at the
same time
this regime in 1984
and this regime in howard's zen
exists to repeal the past
because if that can be changed anything
can be changed
and nothing means anything now o'brien
well he tortures winston i mean it is
amazing by the way it's just
exactly what a seminar would be like in
a totalitarian state
and uh as he as he steadily un
you know reveals the truth to winston
along with pain rising and falling
why do we do this to you winston
you think it's because we don't think
that you can be good on your own
and we're trying to improve you no
we don't care about you you are here
as the subject of our power
and since the only competence that has
meaning is
power you know god is explained in the
christian text and in the classical text
the pagan text too
god has explained it as something that
would be omniscient
and and and in the christian god
omnipresent and omnipotent
control everything right well if you
just take all those qualities out except
omnipotent how would we humans be
godlike
we can't actually know everything all at
once
uh we can't be everywhere except through
technology we can
but we can all be all powerful he
explains to winston
and the condition of that is we have to
be torturing you
our god our divinity is expressed
through the fact that you obey us only
through pain
because if you did it for pleasure then
you might be a volunteer
and that would be a limit on our power
if you imagine the most famous line in
the book if you imagine the future
winston
imagine a boot stamping eternally
on a human face
this begins with a kind of liberation
i'll just give you a small example
every school kid learns today that
thomas jefferson wrote the declarative
independence and that he was a slave
holder
and they don't learn anything else they
don't learn
that thomas jefferson wrote in the notes
on the states of virginia
and the contest between the master and
the slave the almighty has no attributes
that can side with us
indeed i tremble from my country when i
think that god is just
they don't read that and and if they did
they would find that there was a
troubled man
they don't know that the first time the
greatest
republic in human history the american
republic expanded
it was the northwest territory and they
don't know that slavery was forbidden in
that territory
and they don't know that the land came
from the slave state virginia ceded to
the federal government
and that from virginia the slave state
and on the motion of thomas jefferson
the condition of the gift with it was
that slavery be eternally
forbidden there they don't know that
now if they knew that what would they
get they would get a list of
characteristics of thomas jefferson that
would take some thinking about to figure
out the truth of the matter
right and the truth of the matter is
thomas jefferson
was a human being and i don't mean
an old-fashioned human being right for
his time
i don't mean that at all i mean
just as we he inherited things
and caused some of his own that were
terrible things
and he regretted those things and he
fought against them
and by the way on the scale of human
achievement
he stands very high there's just no
question about that
right he was a prime agent in
in founding the first republic dedicated
to the proposition that all men are
created equal
he did that right and and by the way
the miracle is not that he was a
slaveholder
there was a lot of that back then the
miracle is that a bunch of slaveholders
founded a republic to abnegate
slavery and in their own intention and
understanding of the declaration of
independence
recorded many times and everywhere
that's what they thought it would do if
you teach people
children that you will teach them
something more than to love their
country although
that is a good in itself you will also
teach them
that the people in in the past even the
great ones
were human and they had to struggle
and they therefore should get ready to
struggle
they should undertake to live a fully
human life
they should cope with the problems and
evils
in them and around them because
everybody's had to do that
instead what we teach them is that's all
so evil and wicked and now it's
all gone and we're perfect you see
and what that fits them to be is slaves
really because if you want an
independent strong adolescent and young
adult
they're going to have to go through some
trials and they're going to have to
develop the sympathy
that their trials are the trials of
every human being
and that will make them more forgiving
of people around them and people in the
past
you see i'll conclude this engineering
project that's going on to remake
history
do you know the common core started with
a bunch of scientists advising george w
bush i know two of them
they're fine people they're people of
good conviction they're just idiots
and and what they were concerned about
was the teaching of math
and you know these guys are natural
scientists engineers a lot of them
and they think everything is objective
right and they think what objective
means is
there's a math formula and it adds up or
doesn't
and so the fact that we're doing
terrible on this and and then they
and see they leave the subject of
mathematics
and teaching mathematics when they take
this step
they ask themselves the question how do
we reform the system
and that is a question of governance
it's not a question of math
i can tell you the key to school reform
because we're big in that
i'm tired of you guys telling me that my
daughter kathleen o'toole is better
better than i am because i've known it
for
her lifetime
the school is the proper sovereign
in an education system the school
because in school
are gathered the parents and the
teachers and the children
and they know each other and they love
each other
and k through 12 education is not rocket
science you do not need outside experts
i mean we are outside experts but what
we just teach them the basics right
and then they carry on
this alteration of history in the
classic
totalitarian novels and also in book
five of aristotle's politics
the grim three chapters there that
explain
how the tyrant persists
it's hard for tyrants to persist he
likes because people don't like them
and they're always trying to get rid of
them but how would they how would they
carry on
they must diminish every excellence
they must diminish solitude privacy
friendship trust people must be in
evidence all the time no privacy but
they must be doing things that are the
things commanded
life has to be busy so you can't
think right and this changing of history
this blotting out of human achievement
which of course
if you study human achievement and you
study it right you will also say
human trials do you think winston
churchill did not live a difficult life
i mean lord he was broke
in 1935 and six and he tried he almost
got out of politics
just before he saved the world and he
was
derided and the conservative government
tried to take his seat away from him in
the parliament
he was at a low ebb and it and you know
he was
sick he was hit by a taxi and laid up
for six months
and he got typhus twice and
he was it was a his life was a terrible
trial to him it's actually the most
heroic period in his life
and there are many and then what
happened
on october the 5th 1938
at the moment that neville chamberlain
was at his
high peak he had waved his paper from
hitler
peace in our time and they have a debate
as they do in britain every time a big
thing
happens and churchill stands up nearly
alone among 650 people
and he says we have suffered an
unmitigated defeat
and its consequences will follow us far
down our path
this he concludes is just the first sip
the first
fortes of a cup that's going to be
presented to us
over and over and that was in october
1938
and in march of 1939 hitler broke the
deal
obviously ostentatiously grotesquely
and now neville chamberlain is disgraced
and this lonely guy
who just could not be stopped
everybody that signs popped up all over
london
what price churchill put up by people by
the way who divided him before
you want to be a hero it's hard duty
and the young need to know that so that
they can grow up to be splendid people
some of them heroes and to take that
away from them you see
it will deprive them of their freedom it
will deprive us of
of our country it will deprive us
finally and worst
of our humanity itself
this has got to be stopped thank you
thank you doc thank you dr arn we now
have time for some q a
if you have a question please make your
way to a microphone on the aisle
we have a question on dr arn's left
well first off i'd like to thank you for
talking about 1984 i
read it last week but my wife's not too
happy because she hadn't finished it
but i'd like to ask you how do you
how do you choose your faculty your
college in other words we
turn our children over to teachers
professors and sometimes we find they do
like a roberts on us
we think they're great and all of a
sudden they change so what
what sort of a policy do you have for
your faculty at your school
thank you that's a good question it's a
unique uh
it's been developed by uh
about five of us uh over 20 years now
uh i'll tell you how it works so you
know i'm i'm a college president
i've never had a job in a college in my
life except this one
and so i don't know how anything works
i like college i would have stayed in
college forever if
katie arne had not come along but
so i'm sitting there and they come in
and they say it's time to advertise for
jobs
and i said okay and they say you have to
prove it it's a budget item
and i said okay these are all
replacement
faculty we're not expanding at the time
they're really asking me the question do
we need to contract
i said okay how do we do it
and they say we go to conferences and we
advertise and we gather up a bunch of
applications and we talk to some of them
remotely
and then we narrow it down and we means
by the way
the department the dean of faculty and
generally searches have to have a member
or two on the committee from a different
department so i learn all this right
and then we bring the three best to the
campus and we interview them and they
give a class talk and
and we try to see who's the best and
then we vote
and you have to approve the hiring of
each person
aha i said i said three and they said
yeah and i said i want to talk to him
and everybody thought that was really
weird and i just didn't know any better
right
and they said you want to talk to him i
said yeah they said why and i said
curious well i found out that i just
love to do it i've
i've interviewed more than 400 people
for faculty jobs now
and also the provost interviews abuse
them and the associate provost and the
dean of faculty and
you know there's about six of us and we
think alike and we interview every one
of them
uh what what do they have to tell us
what do we look for there are three
things
competence in the field and in teaching
in the field
those two and then respect for the
mission of the college
and they all this is something we
introduced they all have to write a
statement in response to the mission of
the college the four things that the
college is about
and we read those statements you know
people who are going to come and teach
chemistry
they have to do it too and you know
there was big resistance about that at
first
uh not anymore now we're all used to it
and that means that when you read these
essays
because you know hillsdale college has
become a really cool place to work
the kids are smart the conditions are
good we pay fine
uh everybody's respectful to everybody
else right
and i say to these professors because
this is what i do and so i've
i you know i probably have interviewed
more people for faculty jobs than
anybody alive i just got to doing it
here's what they're like i mean by the
time they get to me
almost always they're actually inspiring
people
because if you're a college professor at
a good college
most of your life you've been the
smartest person you know
you know and and you know they all think
that by the way
and then they then they're going to join
a whole bunch of people like that
but they have made a choice because
they could go to professional school
they could go to of any kind
they could get into the best ones
they're good they're all good at taking
the test
you know and i like to say in fancy
colleges
it's full of people who are really good
at taking standardized tests
because you know just an act to it and
you can do it and
these guys are like that girls too and
then
they make a choice for something that's
not going to pay them a lot of money
i mean you know they make good money
right but not like a lawyer or a doctor
and that's easier than what they've done
and so i always ask them why they do it
you know the key to figuring out anybody
if you're going to hire them or work
with them
just try to find out what they love what
do they love the most
and whatever that is if you can isolate
it and that's what you need then you can
just rely on that person completely
so i always ask them why what they love
i sometimes say this to them i say
you're a very needy person and they go
am i i say very i said you need things
that are
incredibly hard to get you need
intelligence all about you
you need curiosity you need interest
you need discussion you need calmness
you need beautiful surroundings you need
all of those things you need friendship
and they'll say you know because most of
their you know everybody's younger than
i am now but
mostly they're young you know and
they'll say
ooh that is what i need and i'll say
you realize that that's very hard to get
these days
and they say yeah almost impossible
sometimes they say except maybe here and
i say well you're right
i can give you those things would you
like to know what i need
and you know very much would they like
to know and i always tell them
there are two things that you have to do
and you need to commit to me
on your honor and the college the first
is
you are going to conduct your career in
teaching and study
with intensity until the day you retire
you're not to get tired you're not to
lose your imagination and your spark
this is a commitment for a lifetime you
need to make that commitment
you need to have the attitude so don't
learn it's your fault even if it isn't
that's the first thing that's your
calling that's what you've chosen
you should do that well the second thing
is
this college is old and none of us alive
today made it
and its beginnings are beautiful you
must never
obstruct its pursuit of its principles
you don't even have to agree with them
although you'll be happier if you do
but you may not divert the college
from its purposes and if you do that try
to do that we'll have friction
and i'm pretty good at friction and so
we tell them that right and then you've
got your deal
and you know we've had
you know no human thing is uniformly
great ours is mainly great
and you know i've hired now myself by
that process
with others i've hired
that's probably 75 percent of our
faculty now
and that means if i go to a faculty
meeting before they got the job
and three times as many as they we've
had several of us who've had that long
talk with them
and people by the way people you know
people who can get a phd
and get a good job a good job in a
college like ours because there aren't
many colleges like ours those are not
people who generally will look you in
the eye lie to you
so yeah that's how we do it and it's
there's nothing more important than that
and
i got mad at a couple of them the other
day and the provost always
because you know some of them are very
frightened about covet
and okay if you're frightened about
covert then you can teach
by zoom the kids will be in a big
classroom watching a tv screen
and uh and you know we do that some
right and i don't mind right
but i got the sense that a couple of
them were thinking that i actually had
to stop the kids
and i said i said what
he said no it's not what you the provost
says it's not what you think
he was he was protecting them i said
if we're going to have an argument about
whether anthony fauci is god
i said i'm getting ready to win that
argument
[Laughter]
we have time for one more question who
says
yeah hi larry um uh i'm i'm here i'm
neil and my wife linda
and uh every sunday we have a community
group
get together and listen to your webinars
and
we learn together about our country as a
group and really thank you for providing
those services i have a two-part quick
question here
how can i talk to my granddaughter or
son and look like the authority on
information
compared to them or when they come home
with a howard zinn
let's say concept how do i i'm just a
grandfather compete with the school
on what the authority on what accurate
information is
and then the second part to that
question is is
how do we you might say let this happen
the howard's inn
and and the curriculum are do we not
have enough conservatives
on the board of education or you know
what can we do to
slow or stop this from happening in the
future what mistakes did we make
okay i'll answer those in reverse order
so first of all
i said why this has happened o'brien
when he was torturing winston was
teaching him philosophy
he was teaching him the direction of
modern philosophy and that is
we've spent too much time this is
machiavelli trying to figure out
imaginary republics let's get on with
just governing the world
which is just another way of saying
let's get power right and so
it was done the the whole movement is
sustained
by the hope that mankind can be in
charge of
everything and by the way also
violate the law of contradiction
which god cannot do do you know that one
of hitler's motives was that
god promised that he wouldn't let the
jews be destroyed
and he wanted to get to a place where he
could look up and say yeah there you go
you see that spirit right that's a deep
drive and it starts with a kind of uh
ambition to make everything right
and it ends with an exercise of power to
make even wrong things right or to
destroy the difference between wrong and
right
and it feeds on itself right it's the
reason there's a great national movement
uh it's it's the reason that what my
friend angelo codovilla calls the ruling
classes
have a wide agreement about all this
stuff right
and why they can look at children their
own children
as things to be engineered as
as opposed to things to be grown see
so that's the answer to that now about
you being the authority
uh if it's howard zen in particular you
have on your side that he's an idiot and
a liar
and mary has written that book
but uh also uh
it is hard because aristotle writes that
the authority of the law
is greater than the authority of a
father
so in an age when the law and you know
just think how it
out how the authority of the law
has multiplied just in the last
six months right our college was closed
for two months
never happened before 175 years
and there is no reason for it this is
not
killing young people
so it's just gone exponential right
and so here's the hope you have on your
side the advantage that you love them
and know them and then you have on your
side
a rare advantage you're a studious
person
that thing you described you're doing
you've been doing for as long as i've
known you
right and so you can welcome them to
that
and you know i i
you've been in a good classroom of
course right but
i mean it's the most magnetic place on
earth
and these classrooms we have today are
scenes of
boredom and despair because they're not
teaching anything
right a a
a good classroom there's always a danger
of fires gonna break out
right it's so it's so fun and so
see and so you cultivate that
and invite them to that and show them
what that's like
and then they will because see there's
no achievement
here the rough way they approach things
is
with in school today they start with
this there are only perspectives
there isn't any truth if you ask a 17
year old who's not in hillsdale college
because we change ours we corrupt them
ask them the meaning of any fundamental
thing and and they'll say
well my opinion is and uh
and they'll state it and then if you say
is that what it is
well that's my opinion i said see you
keep talking about you
what about this thing over here don't
you want to know about that
see they're not they're not taught to
think that way let us
discover what it is because you know the
socratic dialogues
they are elaborate exercises in
definition
what is that thing what is justice
what is good what is truth you see
and the the only hope
is the natural affinity of the human
being for that
activity and so my advice is create it
for them
as you are creating it for yourself
so please join me in thanking dr arne
[Applause]